I just got a bunch of pictures from
Warner Brothers vaults of the actual
original costumes I think the costume
Mark's really good and it's just without
Frills because today people have seen a
lot of different superhero costumes so
it's how do you make it look believable
how do you take this outrageous concept
of a guy who flies around and turn him
into something real
hey GQ I'm James Gunn and I'm going to
break down my top five favorite comic
book movies
I think I'm worth listening to about
comic book movies simply because I've
made so many comic book films and
superhero films I've made at least oh my
gosh I don't know how many superhero
movies I've made at this point something
like six or seven I guess if you include
the movies I've produced like The
Avengers movies then it's really a lot
oh hello
I know right whose balls did I have to
fondle to get my very own movie I think
coming in at number five I'm gonna go
with Deadpool the first Deadpool and the
second Deadpool actually are two of my
favorite comic book movies they came on
the heels of the Guardians film they
were even more of you know comedies in
the Guardians films are and they were so
well made so heartfelt and fun and Ryan
Reynolds just kills it I think Deadpool
is a perfect adaptation of a comic book
because the comic book is very much
tongue-in-cheek very much breaking the
fourth wall all the time talking to the
audience and I think the movie does that
really well but somehow also keeps it
more grounded and gives it a little bit
more heart than the comics have if you
could see me you'd understand looks on
everything looks are everything you ever
heard David Beckham speak
it's like a mouth sex to can a helium I
think Ryan Reynolds got this far on a
superior acting method Love is Blind
Wade no
you're blind Brian's such a funny guy I
think it along with like Robert Downey
Jr is Iron Man or Christopher Reeve at
Superman he's one of the all-time great
comic book you know icons
[Music]
foreign
number four I'm going to say old boy now
a lot of people don't know that this is
a comic book film but it's based on a
manga and it's a Korean film it
reinvented action and it really ushered
in the new era of Korean Cinema which
has continued to this day they still
probably make the best action movies in
the world but as a movie it's just
incredibly cinematic incredibly colorful
really kind of gross but also beautiful
and shocking at the end it has real nice
twist at the end so it works on every
level
one scene that sticks out it's obviously
the hallway fight that was a huge
inspiration to me and you can see our
own version of a hallway fight in
Guardians 3. different versions of
hallway action fights have been great
whether it's in old boy or the raid
another great action movie we have one
in the suicide squad and now in
Guardians
sorry do you think we know each other
you tell me my third favorite all-time
comic book film is a History of Violence
directed by David Cronenberg one of my
favorite directors I love so many of his
films from dead ringers to Naked Lunch
but my favorite movie of his is probably
a History of Violence Viggo Mortensen
stars in it he's fantastic and it's a
really amazing movie about a guy who's a
former killer who's trying to live this
normal life and gets wrapped up in his
past when I saw History of Violence I
also like old boy I didn't know this was
based on anything I didn't know it was
adapted from a novel or especially
didn't know it was adopted from from
comic books in the graphic novel I just
saw it as a movie itself so it didn't
have to live up to anything it didn't
have to overcome anything it was just an
amazing movie in and of itself that's
emotional and passionate and the
violence and the action is shot really
well I mean I really was influenced by
History of Violence I was influenced by
the way that it didn't play like an
action movie you don't look at it and
say oh that's an action movie but if you
watch the way Cronenberg shoots the
action sequences in the movie it's
really spectacular and really deft door
[Music]
I think Cronenberg has a way of turning
the world just slightly to see something
really ugly about it in a beautiful way
if that makes any sense and History of
Violence does that he just turns this
normal American family just slightly and
we see into its soul and it's not the
most beautiful thing in the world
there's this wonderful of all the
wonderful things there's a wonderful sex
scene in the movie between Viggo and his
wife on the steps when she discovers
like starting to discover who he really
is I'm not a big sex scene guy I don't
take sex scenes apart in the same way I
take action scenes apart but I somehow
really remember that scene because it
was so raw and so passionate and so real
thank you
and usually sex scenes just seem like
I'm actually usually waiting for them to
be done or they seem like unnecessary or
just exploitative you know so this this
wasn't like that at all this was a real
part of the story
[Music]
excuse me not so bad
number two I'm gonna have to go with a
movie that changed my life and that's
Richard Donner's Superman this one is
important to me historically it's a
great movie but it was also a movie I
saw as a kid that affected my life a lot
and I remember seeing it to Paris Cinema
in Manchester Missouri when it was first
released strangely the same exact
theater that Jim Lee who went on to
create so many great Comics characters
saw it in in St Louis because we're both
from there what was taken up in this
movie and I remember when I was a child
I had seen Star Wars and that was like
such a big magical moment for me and
this was the next big magical movie
[Music]
I've got you
you know at the time they did exactly
what we're doing now they're going
through tons and tons of actors to see
who captures that Spirit the thing they
don't talk about much when they talk
about Christopher they talk about his
pureness his hope his goodness they talk
about you know the way that he plays
Clark is being so different from the way
he plays Superman and how he can turn
that on in an instant but there's this
playfulness about Superman this when
he's saving a cat he's got that wry
smile
nothing am I frisky
wrong now
and that is one of the best parts of the
movie is the playfulness of Superman he
enjoys what he's doing he likes helping
human beings and he likes saving them
they just did the costume from the
comics and they did it very simply and
it works really well the colors work
well I just got a bunch of pictures from
Warner Brothers vaults of the actual
original costumes I think the costume
looks really good and it's just without
Frills which was easier back then than
today because today people have seen a
lot of different superhero costumes so
it's how do you make it look believable
how do you take this outrageous concept
of a guy who flies around and turn them
into something real I think that you
know what we're doing is is different
it's its own thing but I'm definitely
influenced by what Donner did with
Superman and what Christopher Reeve did
with Superman and and Margo Kidder who's
fantastic in the movie she's really the
heart of it in a lot of ways
[Music]
The Fortress of Solitude is an amazing
set it's really like the look of it was
created through those Donner Superman
movies and I think it was a magical
location that wasn't something that
we're familiar with but that was so well
done and actually built Big sets and
that's influenced me a lot we have some
of the biggest sets of all time in the
Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. it's
great to actually have real practical
sets for these strange locations so the
you know Actors and The Crew kind of
feel what's going on when we're there
and it just looks better than having
everything be a total CGI Fest
[Music]
ha
please keep wait wait
how could there be two Spider-Man there
can't be two Spider-Man
[Music]
can there my favorite superhero movie in
my favorite comic book movie is an
animated film it's into the spider-verse
this movie works from start to finish it
does not have a bad beat in it the
action is amazing the emotion is amazing
the voice acting is incredible it's well
directed well written and I just don't
think that there's been a better
superhero movie than into the
spider-verse I think that you know into
the spider-verse is truly the first you
know comic book Multiverse movie they
did it in such a balanced and real way
there weren't a lot of plot holes like
there are in a lot of these Multiverse
movies they thought everything through
and it was just really tight and if
there's one thing I respect a lot in a
screenplay and film is to be elegant and
to not be doing all this stuff that goes
off from the center of the film and it
does at its days pointed the entire time
are you from another dimension like a
parallel universe where things are like
this universe but different and in your
Spider-Man in that universe but somehow
travel to this universe but but you
don't know how well that was really just
a guess being able to see all these
different Spider-Man characters Miles
Morales and you know Peter and all the
other characters working together in one
movie it was sort of a dream come true
for a kid who loved you know Spider-Man
as much as I love Superman and Batman
growing up I think that spider-verse
really influenced me in terms of trying
to make high quality animation that is
not secondary there is an advantage to
these animated films because you do plan
out everything you kind of draw it as
you go along you don't go on set and
film it it's costing you millions of
dollars and then you come back with the
footage and then you have to see if it
works or not I think it's one of the
reasons why there are so many good tight
animated films and more often than not
they're better than live action films
movies that almost made the list were
Deadpool 2 Iron Man for sure V for
Vendetta is another one that almost made
the list Spider-Man homecoming I think
is fantastic there were a lot of movies
I really love that almost made the list
but I had to choose five and so you know
I may wake up tomorrow and think I made
a an enormous mistake that I can take
back can you just give us a quick drop
of the list with your movies in it but I
would I can't they're like you know my
movies are like my children so I can't
say one that I like better than the
other I mean listen with guardians one I
was proud of how we did something that
was considered pretty outlandish at the
time but did it in a mainstream way that
spoke to audiences all over the world
that was a big accomplishment for me for
the second movie I was really proud of
how you know we really told this story
about a you know adoptive father and his
son and how that came together and how
many people have ripped me over the
years saying I you know I finally like
forgive my stepfather for all this
whatever they put me through it's
changed people's relationships with
their family members for Suicide Squad
The Suicide Squad we really took big
risks and big swings and did ridiculous
things that I thought was like a much
more chaotic approach to cinema and I
learned a lot through that and I
personally learned a lot through how to
use a camera on that film and for
Guardians 3 I'm just really proud of the
way that we you know really gave each of
these characters the dignity they
deserve and gave them the ending they
deserve
all right GQ thank you very much these
were my top five favorite comic book
movies they all might change tomorrow
who knows but thank you very much for uh
joining me and I'll see you soon
[Music]